(pleasant music)
- [Narrator] The marshy
region in the south of France
is home to herds of white Camargue horses,
one of the oldest and rarest
horse breeds in the world.
Since the 1500s, the people of Camargue
have upheld a tradition
dedicated to caring for them.
(foreign language)
For centuries, there has
been unwavering respect
and devotion to the Camargue horses.
They appear in artwork, cave paintings,
and have long been inspiration
for the people of the region.
However, in recent years the population
is no longer as strong as it once once.
(foreign language)
Every day, Marie and other guardians
feed, groom, and work
their horses on the land.
(foreign language)
Despite all the guardians' hard work,
for them it is worth it.
The Camargue horses are
unequivocally intertwined
with their regional identity.
To uphold the tradition
that keeps the breed alive
is the genesis of their passion.
(foreign language)